digamos que tenemos la función fx igual
a logaritmo natural de x + 5 entre x
menos 1 muy bien esta es nuestra función
y nos preguntan quién es la derivada de
f muy bien quién será la derivada de f
así que te invito a que hagas una pausa
y que pienses cuál sería la respuesta a
este problema
bien entonces yo yo digo que al menos
hay dos formas de hacerlo una que es muy
fácil pero de verdad es muy fácil y otra
que es un poco más difícil muy bien
entonces en este vídeo vamos a resolver
ambas formas primero vamos a resolver
resolver el fácil tenemos que utilizar
primero las propiedades del logaritmo
natural entonces el logaritmo natural de
un cociente es decir de a entre b es
igual a logaritmo natural de a menos el
logaritmo natural de b muy bien entonces
qué es lo que tenemos ahora si
utilizamos esta propiedad y por supuesto
cuando habló del logaritmo natural estoy
hablando del logaritmo base el número y
muy bien entonces si yo utilizo esa
propiedad en esta función que es lo que
obtenemos que fx es el logaritmo natural
de este cociente que sería el logaritmo
natural de x + 5
menos el logaritmo natural de x menos 1
muy bien entonces si ya tenemos esto
podemos derivar la derivada de fx será
la derivada de ésta de esta parte menos
la derivada de esta otra parte quien es
la derivada del logaritmo natural de x
más 5 pues es la derivada del logaritmo
natural respecto de x 5 que es 1 / x + 5
por la derivada de x 5 con respecto de x
que es uno muy bien de la misma forma y
bueno esto esto de aquí es la derivada
de esta parte de aquí es justamente esta
expresión y restamos la derivada del
logaritmo natural con respecto de x
menos uno que es uno entre x menos 1 por
la derivada de x menos 1 con respecto de
x que es 1 entonces esta derivada fue la
derivada de de este logaritmo es 1 / x
menos 1 y eso fue simplemente utilizando
regla de la cadena y ya
está la derivada ya es ya ya terminamos
cuál es a lo mejor tú creerás que fue
muy fácil y de verdad lo es ahora te
preguntarás cuál es la forma difícil y
quizás así lo intentaste antes de que
empezáramos a resolver el ejercicio y la
forma difícil de resolver este problema
es no simplificando el logaritmo es
decir utilizar solo regla de la cadena
muy bien entonces utilizando solo regla
de la cadena quien sería la derivada de
f la derivada de f
sería la derivada del logaritmo natural
con respecto a x + 5 entre x menos 1 que
es 1 / x 5 sobre x menos 1 por la
derivada de x de hecho déjenme hacerlo
con otro color digamos
vamos a ponerlo primero aquí así la
derivada del logaritmo natural con
respecto de x 5 entre x menos uno es uno
entre x 5 sobre x menos 1 muy bien sería
algo así por la derivada de lo que
estaba dentro verdad que es la derivada
de x + 5 entre x menos 1 la derivada con
respecto de x de x + 5 entre x menos 1
muy bien y esto quien es quien va a ser
esta expresión bueno uno entre x 5 entre
x menos 1 simplemente tomando recíprocos
o usando la regla del sándwich es x
menos 1 entre x 5 y ahora derivamos esto
verdad y quizás te pase como a mí que a
veces no nos acordamos bien de cómo era
la regla del cociente pero pues eso es
muy fácil porque puede uno ponerlo como
x 5 x x menos 1 a la menos 1 y entonces
ya en vez de acordarse de la regla del
cociente puedes simplemente utilizar la
red
el producto que yo digo que es un poco
más fácil de acordarse entonces como ves
aquí está la razón de por qué es mucho
más difícil que la que el otro método
muy bien entonces quién será esto
simplemente sustituimos de nuevo y esto
es x menos 1 / x + 5 y hay que
multiplicar por esta derivada entonces
si derivamos el primer término con
respecto de x nos queda la derivada de x
5 con respecto de x es 1 por x menos 1 a
la menos uno que es 1 / x menos 1 y
ahora sumamos simplemente derivamos x
menos 1 a la menos uno que es bueno
según la regla de los digamos de los
exponentes es menos x menos 1 a la menos
2 verdad que es uno entre x menos menos
uno
al cuadrado muy bien y luego
multiplicamos por este que no le hicimos
nada verdad entonces multiplicamos por
equis 5 muy bien ahí lo tienen vamos a
bajar un poco y si reescribimos esto
todavía más esto es x menos 1 entre x
más 5 vamos a simplemente vamos a
simplificar esto esto es 1 / x menos uno
menos x 5 sobre x menos 1 al cuadrado
muy bien ahora qué pasa si nosotros
hacemos la distribución de este producto
bueno veamos que el primer caso este
numerador se cancela con el denominador
verdad es decir si hacemos este producto
nos queda x menos 1 se cancela con x
menos 1 y nos queda uno entre x 5
- y ahora vamos a ver si ahora
multiplicamos este número por este otro
tenemos que x menos 1 se cancela con uno
de estos x menos 1 y el x 5 se cancela
con este x + 5 y nos queda 1 / x menos 1
y esto es la derivada de f y que para
nuestra suerte obtuvimos el mismo
resultado que antes pero como verás en
este caso fue mucho más difícil que el
primer método